[Music]
this is a theocratic fascism
being hammered into place
[Applause]
[Music]
judge amy coney barrett
thank you very much mr president
[Music]
the attempt to put amy tony barrett on
the supreme court
is just a blatant last-ditch attempt
for president trump to steal another
four terms
let the people decide
we're in a global pandemic and they're
trying to rush it through
illegitimately trump is trying to rush
this
confirmation through so that he can
challenge the results of the election
[Applause]
[Music]
amy tony barrett reflects our values
and our principles she is here to uphold
the constitution of the united states
and that is what we stand for
we are hoping and praying that we fill
that seat because it's time we have a
justice for life
[Music]
you will be arrested
please don't touch me